- [Patricia] And did you move to LA?
- [Kelly] Girl, yes, but we
moved to LA and we're not very..
It's not LA, it's just cities.
We like being out in the country.
And so, we actually recently
got a place in Montana.
I hear you you love Montana.
- I do.
- [Kelly] We just got
back like last night.
- Oh, you did?
- Yes, that's why I'm so excited.
(Patricia laughs)
Just on a high.
- Well, Montana is just gorgeous.
I mean, the summertime
is like fly fishing,
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And they have double
rainbows every day basically.
- [Kelly] I know, it's the
happiest place on earth,
- [Patricia] It's kind of magical.
- [Kelly} Disney World
Has nothing on Montana.
- [Patricia] No, exactly, yeah.
- [Kelly] It is, I was so
like, "Ugh" before the weekend,
and now I feel refreshed, but...
- And we go there for Christmas,
- [Kelly] Oh, we too
are going for Christmas.
- And we chop down our own Christmas tree.
- That's what my husband
does, he grew up in Wyoming,
he did that.
- Oh, he did, yeah.
- So, we're doing all of that this year.
My familiy's coming, I
can't wait to get snowed in.
- Yes. (laughs)
- [Kelly] I'm very excited.
We have a video of a fish
you caught, I think, right?
- Oh, yeah, we do like a little,
you have to do catch and release there,
so, that was the biggest
thing is to be able to
unhook the fish.
They're small.
(Kelly laughs)
Not like a huge... I'm not
holding it up like this.
- [Kelly] I love it.
We catch and release too
unless we're gonna eat it,
sorry, people, but we eat fish,
but I think if you are
going to kill something,
you might as well eat it
or you're wasting it, so
- Right, exactly, yeah.
- But I get that though, we release too.
Fly fishing, don't you feel
like you're in that movie?
- [Patricia] Yes!
- [Kelly] What's it, River Runs Through?
- [Patricia] Yes, I
filmed it where we are.
- [Kelly] Yes, I know!
- [Patricia] Yes, that's the
first time I saw Brad Pitt
in that t-shirt.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Woooo!
- The hair.
- I remember sitting in
the movie theater when he
came out of the river in that tshirt,
- [Kelly] It's unfortunate, wow.
- both my friend and I audibly
gasped in the movie theater
(gasps)
(Kelly laughs)
And my husband was
sitting right there too.
(laughs)
- You're like, "I'm just
kidding, it was just shocking."
(Patricia laughs)
(laughs)
Well, when you're not in
Big Sky, how do you...
Cause we just moved here,
how do you wind down here?
- Do you like to sweat?
- Um, I like hiking if
that's where you're going.
- No.
- Okay.
- No, this is...
- If you're going like, spinning, I'm out.
- No, not spinning.
You lay on a table,
- [Kelly] I'm in.
- It's like an Urban (laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah, I'm in.
- It's an Urban sweat lodge,
- What?
- you lay on a table, they
wrap you like a burrito,
it heats up, they put headphones on,
you can watch Amazon, HULU, Netflix,
They bring you water, it's the most...
- You're just sweating out toxins,
listening to music or movie.
- [Patricia] Yes, and
your heart rate goes up,
and you burn calories, laying
there watching TV. (laughs)
- We found it!
(audience cheers)
We found the miracle!
- I will give you the information.
- [Kelly] You're gonna see me there.
- It's my favorite place.
- That sounds awesome.
- I love it, yeah.
- Oh my gosh, okay, I'm in, I love you.
Okay, is it easier to
relax though, now that...
you have four sons, right?
- I have four sons, yes.
- [Kelly] We have four kids,
but four sons is a whole different thing.
- Yeah, you know, they're
all out of the house now.
I'm an empty nester.
- [Kelly] Is it cool though?
- [Patricia] It's nice,
it's quiet, there they are.
It's quieter, it's less smelly,
- Boys.
- I mean, I remember, I
was making scented candles
with Martha Stewart, as you do,
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- And I said to her, "How
about putting rosemary in,
is that a good scent for candles?"
She said, "That's much
too strong for candles."
I said, "I have four boys at home,
there's no scent that is strong enough
(Kelly laughs)
to cover that smell."
- That's like touring with boys.
I love you, band.
(Patricia laughs)
But touring with boys in a bus is like,
"what is that smell?"
- Yeah, uh huh.
- Like, I don't understand it.
- [Patricia] Yeah, and
now, when I visit them,
and my son said, "You know,
my friend's mother's always
coming, when they come
they do the laundry."
and I'm like, "You know
what? I will die for you,
I will not do your laundry anymore."
- You can do your own laundry.
(Patricia laughs)
I've been doing my
laundry since like seven.
- Yes, me too.
- [Kelly] Grab the washing
machine and take control.